boy now I look like done yet we were
solving for 3 30 ok I have gone all the
way around the unit circle these are the
only two solutions that exists this is a
bit of a problem for me why is it busy
ok we know from the fundamental theorem
of algebra I ought to have not one not
two but three solutions and if you learn
more ok so therefore I need to keep
going now this is everything for 3 in
this is everything from not to Dubai so
I'm just got to keep going right now I
could go backwards but that's going to
be a bit confusing I'm just going to
keep going forward now remembering that
the period of cosine is is is 2 pi ok
the next solution is just going to be
this plus 2 pi I think make it easy for
yourself ok now to hire six Python 3 so
the next solution should be a plan on
three now I I could sort of say why look
I've got three solutions now as it
happens I can however i want to show you
why we can actually ignore me so I'm
actually going to go what's the next
solution going to me it's going to be
remember how we got this it was this
plus to hire well the next one read this
plus too high right so this is 10 pi on
three yes I know I've go fast no wrong
way past but I'm saying like if all I'm
doing solving this right this is no
demand restriction on it yet ok I need
to be able to say why I'm going to
this goes on now I need to I need to try
and work out again which are my
solutions your ease things should tell
you I should just think about the first
three and those are good instincts but I
need to justify this okay we already
know we can't have four or five or six
or infinite so how is it that i actually
get rid of like not just ignore and say
doesn't matter in this context what does
it mean why is it that i'm getting an
infinite series of solutions whereas if
I just went to this if I was like
approximately intersection you'd never
end up with my decisions what is it
about the approach that we have taken
that generates this intimacy receivers
it's this trick right clearly its trick
and the fact that these are circular
function you're going round and round
round you'll keep on getting solutions
forever ok so if triggers was introduced
to problems trig is what I'm going to
use to eliminate the problems
periodicity is the issue here right so I
want to think about neighbor like this
cause oh sorry ten pile of three
hesitate if I to take something like
cause all of 10
think about this right because of the
way cosine looks okay
we're ten thousand three where is
temporarily next to its part 3 i'm
actually over here somewhere art I'm
sorry wait yes it's it's it's actually
sort of here is so going past so what I
should be assuming is going to hear I
should have some overlap with over here
do you agree with that now you can get
rid of this you can deal with it lots of
railways the east way I think it's just
to say well clearly right 10 PI on 3 is
2 pi take away think about it 2 pi to
plus 25 i'll start it sputters in life
ya gotta put a bomb pops it soon x + 4
vampire right is it for for your hands
forward because this guy's 6-3 right but
you can see here because of the periodic
periodicity of cosine right this is just
call us for pylon 3 right this is the
reason why I can get rid of it because
it overlaps with one of my solutions I'm
not just ignoring it I'm saying for the
fact that actually I have accounted for
it it's just the same solution over
again ok so I'm going to say therefore I
really should have had that like you
there for 3 theta equals these
3 solutions okay and you can go ahead
and you can do this for any of them but
these are the smallest ones so i might
as well keep the smaller solutions like
if i wanted to i could have kept this
and not that but why would you okay all
right yeah questions know what a wide
that you have a free day yeah okay so
think about a pound three what solution
is going to overlap with okay it's going
to go over 2.3 but but there's something
I haven't finished yet which is at the
moment I'm solving for 3 theta 3 theta
right so in fact I should be solving for
theta because that's what's going to get
me back to X do you agree with that so
it's in my interest to actually keep the
first solutions and to see I should get
3 and must get through I can't get any
fewer than three right so it's like even
though this might overlap I need I need
extra shin from somewhere when you
divide through by three you can see
actually it's not going to cause an
issue because suddenly these are not
causing the same problem as before like
there's not the overlap that you're
going to notice because these are off by
six pi online which is not just the
period right so I got three solutions
this is also good I actually want X
naught theta so I'm going to have to
take Kurt I very
ok so here are my solutions facts that's
it ok now do I solve it I have solved it
I'll to power 9 4 5 98.9 no exact values
or anything like that at least not exact
values that can be found simply so I
stopped these are the solutions for this
and there we decimals right we could
have used Newton's method or harming the
internal to find these but look I have
them exactly isn't that brilliant ok you
can see our extension to and gets me a
better answer than extension 1 methods a
month ok so I'm almost there what do I
do when you have a look at Part C what
piece of information links you from Part
B impulsively yeah that because a pie
online can be written as because hi
okay oh yeah okay so clearly there's a
relationship during this guy and this
guy but actually that's not even though
i'm going to make use of that that's not
the main piece of information i need to
connect these all together what I need
here is to add them in some way right at
the limit then just a disconnected bunch
of things just a disconnect a bunch of
things but in order to add these up I
need to invoke something about
polynomials because they're related to
each other okay let me finish this
really quickly all right so what I'm
going to say is bye summer fruits for
the original polynomial right here in my
alpha beta and gamma like so close to PI
0 9 plus cos 4.9 plus cos a pie or nine
now careful what is the summer fruit
careful careful careful careful zero
this is a cubic the first term is 3 and
there's actually a sneaky 0 x squared 5
in there and that's the coefficient that
we want right so minus B on a is in fact
minus zero on one do you agree so I
strong also yeah all right thankfully
does my favorite names now I'm always
there like this is 0 so this looks
promising but of course as a raid on his
list I have something that looks wrong
that shouldn't be there it's okay don't
fret what's the easiest way to get from
there to here what's the relationship
between my own 989 they are they are
supplements out there or supplements so
I'm just going to take advantage of that
you can't use an identity here but like
in life in my experience the identity is
so much you memorize compactly how
people screwed up like and fudge it that
you might've still like this this is
minus kaadhal pi minus pi 09 do you
agree with that it's just the supplement
and this is just going to run a long
forms out and doing up myself o space
this is the simple tree extension a
simple simple one cause a minus B this
is going to be colors a caused B is a
minus there so what's the sign of mills
plus sign a sign big right but you can
see close by of course it is think about
it because high is down there it's
negative 1 and sine pi is of course 0 so
i've got negative negative cost pie or
nine which is cause plan on dying just
like I was hurting